[Music]
the zone of interest is not a story in
the sense of a normal film it's a about
a man who has a lovely life with his
family he's very good at his job they
live in the country in a lovely house
with a lovely Garden he also happens to
be the common on of
Al their Garden Wall was the same wall
on the other side that was the death
camp now early research the photographs
the hos family album is in this
Garden you see everything you see Paul
and the slide and the greenhouse and the
rest of you never see the wall that AB
buts the
camp there've been films about
perpetrators and a lot of those examples
have shown perpetrators quite villainous
you know um not us so I wanted to avoid
the artifice of Cinema I wanted to look
at them more forensically he said we
don't want to make this like a movie set
there was no lighting there was no film
gear on the set only like cameras so
they wired the whole house with the
cameras some of them were hidden some of
them were visible but no camera people
were behind it we were all in a trailer
over the wall basically how it affects
the acting you definitely knew you were
all alone with the history with all the
things that were present in that house
that I cannot even
explain it was really important critical
in fact for the entire project to be as
close to the truth as one could possibly
get to create present tense as an exp
experience and also allow the audience
to be able to project themselves onto
these people and see themselves very
easy to see these people committing
genocide and thinking they're monsters
that's not me I'm
safe but they didn't start as much
murderers they started as boyfriend and
girlfriend having dreams about their
future what they wanted for themselves
is not that dissimilar to what everybody
wants and the whole idea of this project
was to be confronted by a reflection of
ourselves on some
[Music]
level